さあではむしろ話をしましょう
皆さんムシっと聞いてですね後ろ寿命ってだいたいどれぐらいの棒だと思います
学生さんだったら実習でですね使うとすればショウジョウバエとか解雇とかですねまぁ
だいたい彼らの寿命って
2ヶ月ぐらいなもんですねにょにヶ月
まぁだいたい昆虫のジェットそんなもんです多くの昆虫の締めはそうな
思うんですじゃあ2ヶ月生きる昆虫にとっての頃
100年
これどういうスケールかといいますと例えばサールロ中目を
まあざっくり30年としましょう30年のモロに対してこの600バエ
つまり一番八千年生きる猿がいるのかという問いになります
馬鹿なことを言うなとお思いでしょう100連生きる昆虫昆虫ってだいたい短い10秒
はかない命の代名詞ですよね
これは100年生きるんだと言うこういう仮説についてお話ししましょう
皆さんばから話だと今思い大前でしょうもう一度私の公演が終わるときにもう一度お
伺いします
これ皆さんくんあの同じあのおなじみがないかもしれませんが
シロアリの場ですシロアリがあったり今上にも展示してありますが
チロありであったりありであったり8であったり
いわゆる社会性昆虫と呼ばれるもの
先ほど出てきた症状ばや解雇と大きく違うところが役割の分担が進化しているという
ところです卵ムコの女王
あるいはあらゆる労働に従事する働きあるいは頃リーをすぐ他の天敵から守る兵隊アリ
こういう防衛ロード繁殖といった
彼の分業が進んでいくこれが社会性昆虫のシンカーの道筋ということになります
4割というので多くの人を
白くなったありだと思っている方が多いかもしれませんがシロアリとありというのは
全く別の生き物です
ありとシロアリ一番大きな違いはですね
ありの社会というのは働きアリはみんなメスですそして情報しかありませんしかし白い
の社会というのはいうラバ
男女共同参画社会です我々よりももっとずっと
男女共同参画社会ですから筒の中には小嬢と一緒にこの思いますね
働きアリの中にもおおすごいてメスもいて
そして
一緒に働いているというそういう社会です
この写真というのは高さぼシロアリ上にモスを展示してますけれども熱帯ロー
これは医療も手で通った写真ですけれどもかなり
南の方の白いですがもっと身近なところに持っていきましょうヤマトシロアリ
これなら我々のこれ今いる子の周りにたくさんいますこの京都大学のキャンパスの中に
もたくさんいます
これはをヤマトシロアリ最も身近な白いの話をしましょう
gw明けには2から爛漫という離れオスとメスのを離れが飛び立ちますそして
であった一夫一妻オスの一匹の花やり止めする一匹の羽アリが最初の巣を作るそして
一夫一妻でそう立ち上げてもうた孫が生まれ
一匹用地が出てきてますね tivoli てもよーっ
中タマゴから出てきた幼虫はもうすでに立派なシロアリの形してます足が6本だ
ですの創設はですから最初の1匹のオス最初の1匹のメスこれを創設放送雪上という
ふうに呼びますね
で今卵が産まれましたそして幼虫が出てきました始めるうち働きませんがそこから
大きく二つ人生が分かれます
一生働いていくし
人生を送るかあるいは最終的な刃形になってそう飛んで行く繁殖を担うようなそういう
人生を送るかこれ大きく二手に分かれます
働きアリは脱皮しながらより大きな働きアリなって一部は最後ヘイターになります
けれども
こちらに行くと言ってちっちゃ肌が既にあります父母ら大きくしながらタップ
してタップして最後顔して早割になりまた酢を盗んでいった新しい巣を作っ
ジョーは西川の大きなお腹になって卵で弾丸追うようになっていきますが
ですの中でオーバー死にましたジョーが死にました
最初の防衛上が死んだらスはそれで諦めるか
そうじゃなくてその中では次の王であったり次の場だったりが飛ぶのをやめて巣に
とどまってその中で次の
オート過剰というのが出てきますこれ我々
最初の王とか情報に対してに goo とかに事情というふうに言います
ですから例えば場が1匹では卵を産むスキルが足りないとなると補充路上を補充のに塩
城がその中からたくさん出てきて繁殖を継承するということが起きます
大きなコロニーになってくるともちろん最初の場は大らかを聞くして
コート講義をして繁殖してますが
こちら見てみるとそれと同時に俺後期の場がいっぱいいっぱい出てきてますね
これは先ほどの経路でその中で新しく出てきた女王ですねこの情報と最初の女王のこの
上集団とこの桜が交尾をして繁殖を継承しているということになりますねもっと巣が
大きくなってくると
あそこにまだ最初の王がいますが創設をはまだいます
この頃になってくるともう数百のに事情が出てきますねこれはつの中から最初一夫一妻
ですを立ち上げたその娘の中から新たな情報というのが出てきた繁殖を継承している
わけですこれによって一気に反し武力を拡大するわけです
じゃあ皆さん考えてみてくださいこのオート
この
沢山出てきた女王の関係ってーどういう関係ですか
どう考えたって最初1匹ロースト1匹のメスが入ってその娘が常に繰り上がったわけ
ですからこれは父親と
等沢山の娘が条理なって
父親と娘の pg 後輩をしているとそれで卵を産んでいると誰がどう見てもこの写真
を見ればそう思いますね我々もそうでした
しかし kg 後輩って我々もまあ親子を後輩とか違法な法律で禁止されてくらい
有害なわけですね近親交配をやることによって有害な遺伝子が方ばになって発言して
しまうあるいは
遺伝的多様性が一気に下がってしまいますのでコロニーとしては大損害になりますです
からなる p 人工花さけ
なきゃいけないけれどもほとんどの頃にはこういう状態で維持されているわけです
じゃあシロアリってそもそも近親交配する昆虫ラーのシロアリにはこういう記事近郊尺
性て当てはまらないのっちゃ話になります
なんかおかしいですよね
実はよく調べてみるとここには
大きなし
新しい仕組みというのが3つ買ってきましたこれ見てみてくださいこれ今桜の遺伝子を
見てみると
桜の遺伝子これ12つをダウンがありますねは ab型としましょうかあこれえーる
遺伝子も b の遺伝子も働きアリの遺伝子の中には両方どちらか必ず一方父親の遺伝
子が入っていますね
そう
と母はへの遺伝白必ずセットで生まれて聴いてますつまり性を使って働きアリってのは
作られています
沢山出ていたあのに事情を見てみましょう
に事情の中にはをものあるべき oo の遺伝したらひとつもありません
つまりたくさん出てギターのスローかが出てきた虹お嬢達と王は赤の他人です
ています
じゃあどうしてどうやったそうなものが出てきたのか
実は最初の女王は交尾をして働き夜リヤ羽アリつまり痛い的対応する必要な部分には性
を使えます
でもそれと同時にこの
ジョーは
精子を使わずに自分の遺伝子だけで単為生殖のスライド分身を作ることができます
実は
性が必要な働きアリ羽成遺伝的な多様性が必要なところには桜と抗議をした
子供当てていますが自分の後継者となる
女王新しいその引き継ぎてとなる場を作るときには自分の遺伝子だけで
単為生殖の娘を作りますそしてこのターン制仕組み
娘の身に自分の女王位の継承を許します
これによって嬢は自分の補助に入った嬢は自分の遺伝子だけを引き継ぐものを自分の
後継者として当てているわけですこれによってすは膨大にはぁ濁力を拡大できます
いくらでも情報を増やすます
900と友情になります
しかしながら応答娘の交尾ではありませんから
いくら繁殖力を拡大しても近親交配を一切回避した状態で
頃にを拡大できるというそして場がまた年をとってくるダート新たの情報を単位静粛で
作り最初の場はシーンでもう
遺伝的には場は死んでいませんですから最初の王と女王が生きていると同じ
挑ん時対応性を維持した働きアリや羽アリを作り続けることができる
桜が入るということはこう秒して精子を蓄えているわけです
なんで聖書を持っているのにターン成熟の娘をそんな都合よく作れることができるのか
実は昆虫の卵の表面にはこういう穴が開いてます
これリア鳥の卵と違って昆虫の卵の受精というのは彼らができてその後に精子が入り
ますですから昆虫の卵の表面には必ず穴が開いています精子が通るためですその精神力
等ラーナの数を数えてみましょうここのっ
4つこれを見てください0
実は芝居の情報は僕は頭から割合でラン本という
精子が通る穴の開いていない球を見ますそしてこの聖書を受け付けない卵によって桜の
存在下でも単為生殖自分の遺伝子だけで自分の娘を吐くそしてその自分の遺伝子だけで
作った娘を限定て
霧自分の後継者にあっているこれによってコロニーの母塾力を膨大にしながら同時に
近親交配を変え室
そして自分の異例的取り分は絶対に譲らないというそういう仕組みです
最初のうちは有線静粛でコロニーを立ち上げ
羽アリあー働けある作ってますが同時に嘘が大きくなると補充の上後継者をいっぱい
単為生殖で作っていきます
そしていう性静粛によって働きアリア晴れを作る女王
最初の女王が知りましたがターン制宿の襖はさらにターン制宿の娘を大西祝によって
作るそしてこの膨大な数の単為生殖
の情報集団頭がかかることによって
有性生殖で作った働きアリや羽アリをオーダーなカードを作り続け
害虫としてみれば非常に恐ろしい害虫ですけれどもこれがシロアリのコロニーが大きく
なっても大きくなっても場が増えても
コロニーとして劣化していけない勢いが衰えないその大きな理由の一つですつまり場は
遺伝的には知りません
ジョーは不老不死です年老いてきたらならば次の情報というのは
た大誠塾で作りますから遺伝的なブックがも知れません不老不死です
これは逆に言うと桜が死んだ時点で大は自分の息子
単為生殖でつくるということはこれは負荷もですですからつまり桜が死んだ時点で必ず
母親息子の近親交配が起きます
近親交配の有害な効果を受けるのは桜が死んだときに初めて起こることになりますです
から
桜が長い
記した頃にほど長く頃にが持つということになりますから場が不老不死化したような
シロアリでは圧倒的に強い
選択し全選択がオール中ようについついてかかり続けます
ほうが長生きした頃にをこと得ということになっていきます
これは最大の頃に我々とと最大のこれで大1匹で
場が676ぴ
これおそろくぞうあざらしを抜いて世界最大のハーレムはシロアリのコロニーの中に
あると思います
考えてみてくださいハーレムって言うとなんかこうワクワクするような
何かありませんハーレンぶっていうと
だけどリアルに考えてみて朝起きて奥さんが676人になっていてしかもその奥沢分身
なわけですよね
happy
ハッピーではないという声がとう
私ははっきりかなと言っておきましょうか
じゃあ俺はだいたい何で生きてんのかという話になりますここからはまあ一緒の
フェルミ推定ですけれども
今創設期があって場が入れ替わる中間期があってたくさんの情報が入るまあこれが
ほとんどの頃にはこういう状態でそして桜が信頼と2割以上がちゃんと出てきます
そしている繁殖を継承するただこれは息子母親の近親交配になりますね
ってこういう頃に実際に野外で我々フィードワークを9続けていますどれぐらいの頻度
でこういう頃にが取れるかということを考えてみましょう
そうすると上等最初の譲渡日常が取れるような頃には兄に対してこよう1匹で補充上
たくさんという頃に63
それに対して桜がも
を死んでしまった次の虹方が出てきたコロニーで繁殖注いでる頃にめっちゃ取りません
が4撮れていますね
じゃあ
桜が死んだと先ほど禁止後半のコストがかかると言いましたが
それは筒切り落としかかるかというとそうではありません
pc 後輩がかかって産まれた卵これが働きアリとして労働を担うハラールとして飛ん
で行くこれまでには最低とかに電話かかりますっ
ということは2年間はその近郊尺性の効果というのを受けることはありません働いて
いるはいうせず結構ザク
性が起きない状態で産んだ束頃答えが働いてますから2年間はそのコストはかかりませ
んかかり始めるは2年後からです
じゃあ最低22年頃リーが存在してそして頃にが衰退していったと考えましょそうする
とこの期間が2年に相当しますから
コロニーが大きくなってから少なくとも最初の桜は32年
生きていないとこれ成り立たないということになりますさらに
じゃあコロニーが大きくなる野外で取れるような大きな頃になるまで名護でどれくらい
買えばいいか
我々11年飼ってますかそんなコロニーのレベルにはなりません
もともと長い時間かかりますこの間まだまだも長い時間がかかってます
これを出してみると最短で死んだとしてどんなに三重も各見積もったとしてもシロアリ
の桜というのは
さ43年
生きていないと
こういうデータにはなってきませんね
つまり私よりも年上になっているわけです
そして kc 強いが関わり始めてから徐々にコロニーが衰退し合理的に推論すると4
年ぐらいでおそらくはすコリーは連覇していくでしょう
この合理的な推論4年を当てはめているとどうなるか大ロス平均10秒76年という
ことになります76年これはすなわちアメリカの平均男性
の平均ジムで一緒ですアメリカ男性の寿命と一緒です
アメリカ男性の兵器中76年ですが今アメリカに100歳以上の男性は1万人開くい
ます
つまり190万76を想定した時には100という数字が実にリアルな数字として科学
的根拠をもとに入ってくるということになっていきます
もっといいましょうあー友情頭なくなった不老不死を手に入れたシロアリどれぐらい
いるか我々世界中のシロアリを研究して今ですね
だいたいそれをチェックした種類は立ってる50種類ぐらいですその中で5種類
ああいう単位静粛によって場が不老不死化しているものが見つかってきました
で今お話したい種類についてそういう授業の考察をしています
しかし世界には後3000種類ますすなわち
我々はまだシロアリについて98%はみちですそして二寿命について調べられたのは
まだたったの1種類です推論すらたったの1種類ですから
99.29%は
流れはシロアリについてしりませんしかしながらかなり合理的推論かなり短く見積もっ
て
し代わりの平均寿命は70年を超える
つまりシロアリの中200さを超えているものは
おそらくいるでしょう
そして最初に言いました開口が症状 by てたボーゼル生物
我々寿命の研究をする時に一番使うのってのはこういう短命な昆虫ですね
短命な昆虫の寿命が延びましたという研究は2ヶ月の寿命が三ヶ月になりましたという
研究ですしかしながら社会性昆虫の寿命というのはそういう桁ではありません
社会成功
じゃあいる場合は情報しかありませんがそれでも20年30年という規模で生きると
言われていますそして我々が新たに見つけてきたよーに
シロアリの王となるとですね場ガスブローオフしかしてしまった遺伝的にしろよ場は
知らないという時に桜の寿命に対して強力な選択がかかります
おそらく
生物の寿命について我々が知っていることというのはごくわずかです
99%のフロンティアというのがまだ我々の足元にロコっています
もう一度聞きましょう
100年以上
生存する昆虫は存在しますか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]